In this chapter will explore
how quantum and classical computers
work together to solve one of the most important challenge
in signs accurately estimating the energy of more echoes
and materials we can achieve this
by using a quantum circuit
to generate bids to examples
which will then post process
and diagonalise there a number of all greater
in this family of routines
like sq g and skg and there is a whole course on
the ibm quantum platform devoided
for them and to related methods
for our purposes in this vision will
give the explanation brief
regardless of whether you are using sqv or skg
your goal is to fight igen vectors
and igen values for a hamilton metrics
this matrix might describe the energy of a physical
or chemical system but the same framework
can address many other problem types
such as logistics sometimes
this matrixes are enormous
so reducing the dimensions
of the matrix while preserving important
features of the ground state
can be extremely valuable that's the goal in sqv
we use the quantum computer to generate a useful subspace
one that contain the ground state
we can then project our meltonian matrix
onto that subspace that leaves us
with a small romatrics which will be
much easier to drag analyze
using classical high performance computing we do this
by preparing a trial quantum state
often called and answered
and performing measurements to sample that answers
in the computational basis that gives us
a sample subspace in the computational basis
but what would really want to find
is the true ground state what
if our sample subspace didn't contain
all of the necessary components
if we choose a better answers
we might get a better estimate of the ground state
that brings us to sample based
criel of quantum the animalisation or skudy in skudy
we start with an answers
as before but then we apply some quantum gates that approximate
the time evolution of a physical system
it can be shown that with a few assumption
this leads to guarantees on the overlap between the time evol
answers in the true ground state
both of these all greater start with enormous
meltonian matrix they work somewhat differently
but in both cases the quantity part of the algorithm yields
a subspace that's all of us to shrink our matrix
in which we hope preserve the key features of the ground state
so where does high performance classical computing come
in for the largest meltonians
and for the most accurate estimates of the ground state
even this project matrices can be quite large
therefore leveraging more powerful classical computer capabilities
can help us not
only get better results
also by all owing us to tackle larger problems
to bring it all together
we can represent sample based all grittens
as a combination of different programming models
on a set of hit regimes resources
for example we can represent our all great
as a task workful where we'll have a task
for quantum circuit preparation that overlap
with our target state followed by a task
for transportation which only requires classical resources
to be executed next will be the task
that uses primitives to execute our quantum circuit
which obviously
and them will have a post processing task which itself
might be a parallel deganization all gritter
running on multiple notes
additionally we might want to run
one of those all greatest many times
while we vary our answers
all run them completely in parallel
with different populations
now let's bring it all together with skd
in cold as well here are all our task files
and here all our submission files
in mapping task we prepare circuits.
In optimisation step we're on circus to the best manager.
In execution task with simple bistrics
from the state prepared by
our isa circuit.
That we get out of previous step
and we do our post processing.
So now we're ready to submit our
excuse you work flow.
As you can see everything is writing in the sequence
was dependencies let's wait
for results and we can check our put files.
Here the opened file of optimisation step
where we have our ic circuit.
And let's finally check our end of j
to ration.
From the schedule.
And that's it for the quick demonstration of skudy work flow
all of the cold will be available in the text section
or in the discretion below
and that's it we've now run through a few
concepts and examples that can help you get started with
the management of complex hybrid programs of course
if you do like this only scratches the surface of
everything you can do with the combination of quantum
and classically specific sources to explore more
check out out of the communitation into torals
on the abm quantum platform
and be sure to check out the resources shirt in the text section
or description for more old items
and software thanks for watching.
Yeah the.